hi there steve here again
um
i'm sort of interested in the subject of
pronunciation and uh i've done two
videos now
on the subject and i had some feedback
which i want to respond to and i want to
uh maybe talk a little more about it
from a different angle
the uh there were two comments to my
previous video where
two people took exception to the fact
that i didn't think that the
international phonetic alphabet was that
important the ipa
and one person said something to the
effect of you
uh you can't start imitating the
pronunciation
without being familiar with the entire
inventory of phonemes in a language
and there were some thumbs up for that
i don't agree
okay and i'm going to talk about in this
video why i think the what i call big
picture learning
is much more important than the
individual details like the
international phonetic symbol for a
particular sound another commentator
also along the same lines said that for
example in french you have the sound
and you have the sound
and there is apparently the
ipa symbol for
is a y if i read this correctly and he
said that if you can't make the
difference then you might say instead of
saying merci beaucoup you would say
merci beaucoup and boku means nice bum
uh but
so i'm gonna comment on these things
um first of all
i always say that in language learning
there's three fundamental issues
your attitude
the amount of time you put in and your
ability to notice everything else is
secondary so
uh
most people who learn a foreign language
would like to pronounce well but not
everyone and many immigrants and i
mentioned the example of my father
who lived in canada for
however many 30 40 years
never really was that motivated to try
to improve his accent he didn't feel
that he wanted to be buddy buddy with
your average canadian he wasn't that way
motivated he communicated very well and
he had a very pronounced accent it
didn't bother him he did business here
he had friends here he was happy he
wasn't motivated to improve his accent
which is fine okay however and i've
noticed that very often students
who haven't had
nearly the amount of exposure for
example that my father had they will
often pronounce better because they're
more motivated to improve their
pronunciation and so therefore they
become more attentive to how things are
pronounced they're more motivated to
blend in with the culture
and as a result they end up so they're
more deliberate about it they want to do
it more they
like the culture that they're learning
they end up pronouncing
better
so attitude time and being attentive now
the nuts and bolts and i said in my
previous video that you need to do a lot
of listening to material that has
resonance
i found that even though i lived in
france for three years
uh
my pronunciation in french actually
improved the last few years because i
was
i started enjoying french audiobooks so
i would be i can still remember
uh jogging while listening to uh le
memoir dadrean
by uh marguerite your sonar or uh
i love balzac or i was gardening while
listening to uh liaison dangerous
for example i like classical literature
not everyone does
and
i'm listening to it and i'm i'm caught
up in it just like with italian
listening to i promise esposi or another
great recording by il naratore you
should look them up ilnaratore
punto.com on the internet great source
of audiobooks in italian or in italian
rai has this aleotto de la sera
series on history and so listening to
all this stuff
really improved my pronunciation because
i was focusing on not only the content
but also getting that rhythm of the
language and i think the rhythm of the
language the intonation
is something that uh
you know students of linguistics
sometimes called prosody or something i
don't know that term to me it's just
intonation rhythm
that's much more important than
certain particular sounds
um every language is going to have some
sounds that are difficult i pronounce
swedish quite well but i have a lot of
trouble saying seven
stuff it's a funny s h sound it's a
funny u sound okay i'm happy though i'm
not gonna spend hours trying to nail
that down because i have the basic
rhythm and flow of swedish so that
people listening to me
find it fairly native-like
um i can't imagine a person
say in french who would have a good
sense of the rhythm and intonation of
french and who would say
it just doesn't go with the red boku
boku you would have heard so much that
you would know if you saw a nice ass you
would say
you know
but it is also true so there are some
issues here
uh with regard to special
sounds
either you are unable to pronounce these
which is sometimes the case like people
may not be able to make the uh sound
or
you may not have enough of a sense of
the rhythm
to know when it's
maybe you haven't listened enough or
you're trying to overcompensate and we
have all heard french people who put h's
everywhere i had a friend who uh spoke
english very well but you know there's a
sort of a
market area here in vancouver called
granville island
and he would always talk about granville
hailand
because he knows that he misses on his
hs so he puts h's in where they don't
belong but it's not because he doesn't
know the international phonetic symbol
for h or that he can't pronounce an h he
just doesn't have the proper
rhythm
in the language one thing that's very
difficult in french is the o
and
you know
and very often people get these kind of
mixed up
uh and they call they go for uh uh maybe
they'll have a default oh so no matter
what it is it's pronounced uh
these are so it's not an inability to
make the sound it's that whole
getting used to the flow and the
intonation and and
for that matter as i said with that
polish word penunzer penanze penonse
which is money
i've got that word because i've been
listening to who is she on link
which is a story that we have in all
however many languages
and the word money comes up all the time
or i noticed another word veglum de
vigne i haven't really focused in on it
but in russian vignette
looks viglonde
so i'm picking up on you know little
bits and pieces that start to suck into
place but i'm not worried about it
uh
i'm just allowing that big picture to
flow over me
uh there are rules that can help you for
example the
ah you know if you have e n in french is
pronounced ah most of the time but when
it comes
after an i or a y
uh it's
uh like adrian
uh or uh vegetarian
and so you may not notice that and you
might say adrian vegetarian
and so then if you've had all this
exposure and you see a rule that reminds
you
that in fact it's vegetarian
uh
then that's going to make sense to you
but the idea that before you start out
into a language you can have
all the sounds that they that you can
hear them all that you can make them all
and uh that you know when you know
it's pronounced this way or that way
because not all languages are are
consistent again going to french you
know
donk the c is pronounced but yet very
often the the last consonant is not
pronounced so
all i'm saying is that uh i should
stress too that for people who find
the bits and pieces
the international phonetic alphabet and
so forth uh or specific rules who like
to study that way by all means i'm not
by any means suggesting people shouldn't
do that i always talk about what my
experience is and my experience has been
that that's kind of a distraction
i want to expose myself to as much
of the overall the big picture as
possible and later on there are things
that i'll miss and at that point to go
in and review some rules on
pronunciation probably is a good thing
it's the same as with grammar i can't
possibly
learn all the fundamental rules of
grammar up front and then proceed to
learn the language i first have to get
that massive exposure to the language
and then you know periodically go in and
look at some rules of grammar and now
those rules relate to something um
you know i've had so many experiences of
of people who get corrected on the
pronunciation some specific aspect of
the pronunciation and they go right back
to making the same mistake so
i stress again that
with regard to
uh pronunciation
you have to have that attitude you want
to improve your pronunciation you want
to be one of them
you're prepared to listen a lot to
what is to you attractive content to try
to notice things to try to imitate them
you can always uh i'll finish and then
take the phone call
just a sec here
hello
hello
hello hey walter can i call you in five
minutes
will do thanks bye
that's my carpenter
so before i lose my train of thought
here
nothing against the international
phonetic alphabet i don't use it
uh i find it not useful if i can't
pronounce something you know the polish
l it seems like it's a oh of some some
kind you know uh
yeah i'm gonna have to get used to it
whatever the phonetic symbol for that is
almost doesn't matter to me
i i know i'm hearing it now it's a bit
of a more open l i gotta get used to it
uh but if others find that useful by all
means
however there's no point you know i
don't get the complete dismissal of the
phonetic alphabet all i said was i don't
find it that useful
other people do by all means go for it
uh what else was i gonna say here yeah
and if i can't make the sound or hear
the sound the phonetic alphabet isn't
going to help me however it's as i say
it's possible that i miss things
and at that point some form of attention
to detail which might include the
international phonetic alphabet if you
have learned it
might be helpful
uh there was also a question from one of
my viewers who is working on french and
is studying at university and what can
he do i think was that he
uh
to work on french because he is going to
go to france thereafter and my answer is
go to link lingq.com
we have tons of content in our library
and listen to it or if you're advanced
enough
get some
audio books and ideally
if you get audio books from say 19th
century authors and i loved listening to
ghida mo passa and the balzac and and so
forth you can then import the text from
gutenberg.org
into link
and you can listen to the audio book and
read the text saving words and phrases
uh to build up your vocabulary so that's
my uh answer to that a person whose name
now escapes me thank you for listening
and bye for now